patty my love what's going on how are we
doing well i'd like to know
what i can do um to move forward
progressively i caught my husband having
an online affair two years ago and i'm
still not over it
ah okay so walk me back to that moment
when you caught him what happened
well i think the holy spirit was urging
me to look in his laptop and i did and
right there it was
and i screenshot it all confronted him
with it
and i thought we were going we had just
reconciled after
um three years of separation and
he didn't deny it he says i don't know
what's wrong maybe i'm just having a
mid-life crisis he ended up going to a
psychologist
for a good probably four months and then
she dropped him something came up in her
life and he never went back
i went to marriage counseling on my own
and she gave me some some tools you know
how to
work through it but i i just that trust
is
just been betrayed and i don't know how
to get it back just i just don't know
how
so you were separated from him why are
we all separated
um mental mental and physical abuse
and he's got a drinking problem okay
so you've got you're not psychologically
safe or you weren't
at it for a period of time you were not
um physically safe
and then you you left
you got back together and how long were
you together before you found out that
he was cheating on you
oh we are back together probably about a
year
18 months okay and this is all two years
ago so fast forward to now what's the
state of your relationship right now
um it's much more loving but i find
myself whenever we're in a public
situation
that i am very aware of who else is in
the
in the room in the establishment i
find myself watching him intently
um taking everything he says directly to
heart
and not brushing it off especially if he
starts drinking
and i i just i'm getting to the point
where i just don't know how to deal with
it anymore
do you want to be in this relationship
yes
yes and that's that's part of the
problem i do want to be in this
relationship i'm
55 this is my second marriage his fourth
marriage
yeah but not failing is not a reason to
stay in an unsafe
abusive alcoholic cheating marriage
oh he's yeah he's he has not done any of
the above
aforementioned since i i busted him okay
it's just i i can't seem to get over
that hump and
to let the trust come or not
and you know give him enough rope is he
going to hang himself
it's not the most encouraging analogy of
this guy
you're trying to rebuild with i'm gonna
see if he'll just kill himself
not a super firm foundation to rekindle
a marriage on
here's the thing um kudos to you
right kudos to you patty for for owning
this
one of the biggest challenges in
relationships when when there's
infidelity when there is
a separation of any kind right a
violation of values is
this idea we're going to come back
together and then once we come back
together and you say i'm all in
i'm i am pushing all my cards on the
table i'm all in
back on you then that means you are
committing
to doing the work on your and too to
rebuild trust to allow yourself to be
trusted right because you still don't
trust patty
right to learn to trust him
and you're not doing that so you passed
my initial test which is do you even
want to be in this relationship anymore
why don't you just get out and move on
right and your answer to me was
because i'm 55 and this is two for me
and four for him
are you okay just being roommates and
riding this thing out
i that's kind of what we've been doing
um
why are you why are you why are you
settling for that
you're halfway done patty i know i know
i
i think there's something more in the
horizon i think there's something that
that
that i am meant to stay in this
relationship
i have been praying and praying and
praying and i've asked i'm asking
do i stay do i go do i divorce do i
what do i do and then i went through the
the ramsey solutions and i started
listening to your podcast and then well
you know what i'm going to ask him
so patty wins the last patty when's the
last time
you woke up early before he gets up
and he went and you went and cooked
something that he loves
and he came in all snotty and gross and
making old man noises
and you went up and grabbed his chin and
he looked him out and said i love
you i want you to know that when's the
last time that happened oh
i do that darn near every weekend i i'm
a day shift
person here too but i get up at 3 30 in
the morning he doesn't get up until 8 i
start work at 6 he starts at 8 30. so
when's the last time
he got up before you made you breakfast
and looked you in the eye and said honey
i love you
i'm so glad that you stuck through my
stupidity and my heartbreak and my
addictions and my problems
and i'm so glad we're still here um i
would say back when we first
got together because he doesn't think
he's got a problem
okay you told me he doesn't anymore and
i trust you
i don't believe you but i trust you
those aren't two things he doesn't think
he's got a problem
um he's gotten he's maintained
uh there's no more abuse um
the drinking has gone down to minimal
you you don't want to let this go
no and i'm asking you why
because i love him no no no not the
relationship
why won't you let go of the
just the sandbags you're carrying around
from the last five six seven years
why won't you just let it put it down
and head off into tomorrow
um good question i've tried that i
actually have tried to just let it go
and move forward
no no it's not it's not an ethereal
thing it's not an ethereal thing it's
not something that you just declare
like that one office episode where
michael scott comes out and he's like i
declare bankruptcy it's like that's not
how that works there's a lot of forms
there's seven years you get right it's a
lot of stuff
but there's something about you that is
hanging on to that past
and here's the thing it's not weird that
you are
you were hurt in a lot of different ways
you were married to somebody who was an
alcoholic those are hard hard
relationships because
those are disconnection issues that's
hard you've been through the trauma
there's a part of your brain that is
protecting you
24 7 from this guy right yeah
and there's the other part of you that
says i love him i'm gonna ride or die
with this dude
for as many years as i got left i'm 55
so i'm about halfway done
right because you're going to live to be
110 clevelanders just live forever
right i don't know if that's true for
100 years
all right so you got what
45 right so
here's the thing you have to make this
choice
do i want to live however many years i
got left
teeter-tottering on this relationship
should i stay should i go or i'm
gonna am i gonna cash everything in and
go all in and here's what go
all in means go all in means i'm going
to
be vulnerable and vulnerability is
like if you go look up vulnerable
vulnerable in the dictionary it means
exposed and exposed means i'm it's like
i have a little puppy right now and that
little puppy when she's wrestling with
mother dog will
when things get really tense she'll just
roll over on her back she is exposed
that big dog could bite a hole in her
tummy and it would be all she wrote for
that puppy dog
right so exposed means i'm opening
myself up to the possibility of being
hurt again
and that's what a marriage is that's
what a relationship is
i am going to put all my cards on the
table
i'm going to be vulnerable i'm going to
tell you i love you and i'm still
struggling and then what you're going to
do is you're going to
give yourself an opportunity to be fully
fully loved by this guy
but here's the other edge of that sword
you're going to give yourself an
opportunity for him to say i don't love
you like that
and i'm out right right and so here's
the date and
that pushed me forward yeah well it's
it's not so much
you don't need to push forward you just
need to make a decision am i all
in and all in means at some point
somebody's got to go first
do i think it should be you no but he's
not going to so it has to be
right right right you are right
so what i want you're at i can hear
in your heart you're at it you're at a
breaking point right you're at a
it's got a it's got to be something
other than this either i gotta
just sit down on this lawn chair and say
this is the bait i'm going to fish with
or i'm going to cut the line and i'm
going to start over and nobody wants to
start over at 55 but i'm telling you
what you don't want to be 70
or 62 and have wife number 5 pop along
you don't want to be 62 and have
the old demons of abuse come back
without having gone all
in and had a conversation about how are
we gonna live this thing differently
a friend of mine um she was in her
second marriage
in fact she was a wonderful wonderful
person she told me something
in you know it gave me a reference point
for being a late life
second marriage that i just loved here's
what she said
she said i'm not going to build a
another life with somebody i did that i
was with somebody we
raised kids we moved from the starter
home to the other home and we had a car
and we wrecked a car we did all that
stuff
we built a life and then he passed away
and so what she her the way she shifted
her
her view of the second marriage right
and she was 50 55
the way she shifted that view was i'm
gonna have somebody
in my life and we are going to have more
fun
we're going to take ever burn every bit
of tread off these tires
until we're done until it's all over
so they are at the lake every week they
are
laughing and smiling and carrying on and
dealing with each other's
arthritis and whatever stuff comes up
and they drop off each other at the
doctor's appointments
they have a totally different view they
are not trying to recreate the notebook
they are trying to
love one another and have a blast
and that starts with a conversation
right patty
that starts with you having this
conversation here's how i want it to go
i want you to let your husband know hey
we're gonna have
a dti it's what the kids uh no dtr
that's right that's what the kids call
it we're gonna have a define the
relationship
and he's gonna look at you cross-eyed
because if you were my wife i'd look at
you i don't know what that
means honey we're gonna have a dtr it's
what the kids are doing honey
and then i want you and him this is old
school delony i want y'all to go get
breakfast together
and i want you to tell them i'm going
all in
it's been a couple of years it's been a
year
two years since you came back i've
hedged my bets
you hurt me in the past you know that we
we we're not going to go all
over that again you have
healed from your abusive past you've
quit drinking so much
i'm trusting you that you're not
cheating on me anymore
and i'm ready to go all in here's what
that's going to look like and i'm being
vulnerable here
you can really hurt me right now so be
gentle
but i want you to love me like crazy
i want you to get up early every once in
a while make me breakfast
and i want you to tell me that i'm
beautiful i want you to tell me
that you're so glad that i'm waking up
in the bed next to you even when my
breath stinks
even when my hair looks great all of
that
and i want you to love me like this
and patty you deserve that conversation
you deserve that sort of marriage
and my hope hope hope is that he looks
at you and his eyes tear up and he says
oh patty i'm all in
and he says i was embarrassed and
ashamed for how i treated you in the
past and i've been struggling to come
back and now that i hear that you're all
in i'm all in too baby
i'm all in and here's what that's going
to look like
but just keep one eye open because
here's what could happen he could say
i'm not
i'm not going to do that and then you're
going to have a decision to make but at
least
you know right now you're drowning in
ambiguity and at least you'll know
so um while we're here thank you so much
for that call patty i'm grateful for you
i really want to know how that
conversation goes
and i want to know what the next steps
and hey before i leave this patty i got
to just say this
so many folks i talk to all like day
after day after day
i just want to know what god wants me to
do i just i met with a pastor and i just
what am i supposed to do i've been
thinking about these things i just don't
know what to do i just
just take a step just take a step
we get so paralyzed by what's the next
step we get so paralyzed by what
god is asking us to do we get so
paralyzed by fill in the just take the
next step
and know that love and trust are things
you practice
titanic lied to us the notebook lied to
us
you just gotta practice it and then you
gotta negotiate what that even looks
like together and that starts with that
vulnerable conversation
again while we're here um let's talk
real quick
the hardest thing about moving past
infidelity is twofold number one
you lose trust in somebody else right
they violated
your core values you said you would be
there you said i was the only one
and you violated that and
when someone cheats on you when someone
violates your your covenant
you lose trust in yourself why did i not
see this coming how could i have been
with somebody who was going to be like
that i should have known
now i don't trust anything every time he
says he's going to the store i just
think oh who's he with every time she
says hey i'm just going to the gym i
just like
who she with and you just make yourself
nuts
right so here's the thing
infidelity tells us
a lie which is you're replaceable well
that's not really lie
technically you are right technically
somebody can walk in and say you know
what you weren't the one for me i'm out
that's so scary and so we at the when
you're thinking about coming back from
infidelity you got to remember
every relationship starts with risk not
with certainty
with risk if it's all guaranteed
man there's no desire there if it's all
guaranteed there's no
passion there it's like a relationship
with a math teacher
like i know she's going to be there i'm
going to be there
right my business professor my law
professor i know she's going to be there
i'm going to be there
man that's not that's not a a
a deep powerful strong covenant marriage
relationship right
so if you're gonna stay with somebody
after infidelity
right i don't tell people to get
divorced except in very rare situations
here's the deal if you decide i'm going
to stay
you got to be all in you can't go part
ways in and i know that sets you up to
get hurt again
and that's like swimming upstream right
you can get hurt again you can drown
because going back in that same lake
if you decide you want to forgive to
stay to re build
you've got to do just that rebuild
something new you can't go back to what
was
right so patty you're not trying to
reclaim what happened before
you found your husband's stuff on the
phone you're not trying to reclaim
what once was you're building something
new
whether you're 25 45 55 85
you're building something new you've got
to look at it like we're building a new
tower together
we're not going to sweep up all the old
dust and ash and glass and twist the
metal and try to rebuild it with that
materials nope
we're going to excavate that site we're
going to build something new and we're
going to do it together
and i see it all the time when someone
says i'm going to stay with them
i'm going to stay with that woman but
they only stay part ways
and you're just shooting a hole in the
lifeboat if you're going to be all in
you're going to be all in
you're going gonna have to get a couple
of friends who are gonna walk alongside
you because it's hard to rebuild trust
you're gonna have to have people you can
reach out to you're probably gonna need
a marriage counselor to walk you through
this
if you ask any marriage counselor worth
their assault what's one of the most
common
and um less worrisome things you can
work back from they'll tell you
infidelity
marriage counselors are not scared of
couples coming back from that because
they do it all the time but they both
have to decide we're both all in
we're going to address the underlying
issues we're going to get to the root of
some of these challenges
and then we're going to build something
new we're going to be all in you can
do it